describe la expresión radical usando
exponentes racionales y simplifica y
aquí tenemos la raíz cuarta de cinco a
cuarta b elevada a la potencia 12 y el
punto clave a considerar aquí es que si
tengo la raíz cuarta de algo esto es
igual a ese algo elevado a la un cuarto
o en general si tengo la raíz enésima de
algo esto es igual a ese algo elevado a
la potencia 1 / n podemos aplicar eso
aquí la raíz cuarta de todo esto es
igual a 5 a la cuarta b a la doceava
potencia y todo eso elevado a la
potencia 14 y también sabemos que si
tomamos el producto de algo y lo
llevamos un exponente eso es igual a si
tomamos cada uno de esos términos del
producto y lo elevamos por separado a
ese exponente y después hacemos el
producto hagamos eso esto es igual a 5
elevado a la potencia un cuarto por a la
cuarta elevada a la potencia un cuarto
por b a la doceava elevada a la potencia
ahora 5 a la 14
esto no sé cuánto es pero es lo mismo
que la raíz cúbica de no lo puedo dejar
como 5 en cuarto potencia ya no se puede
simplificar o lo puedo describir como la
raíz cuarta de 5 ahora
a la cuarta elevado a la cuarta potencia
si tienes algo que lo eleva a una
potencia y luego a otra potencia eso
equivale a elevar a la potencia cuatro
por un cuarto déjame escribirlo acá
abajo así es que esto es a elevado a la
potencia cuatro por un cuarto y
finalmente aquí usando exactamente la
misma propiedad de los exponentes esto
es igual a b elevado a la potencia 12
por un cuarto así que todo esto se
simplifica como y aquí voy a cambiar el
orden en el que tenemos estos términos
esto es igual a la raíz cuarta de 5
luego tenemos ha elevado a la potencia 4
por un cuarto lo cual se simplifica como
a la potencia 1 que se escribe
simplemente como a hilo aquí tenemos b
elevado a la potencia 12 por un cuarto
bien 12 por un cuarto es 3
así es que suez de kubica y nuestros
resultados finales entonces a por de
kubica por la raíz cuarta de 5